foreign
Cincinnati hi Sandy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
what's up
so I am excited to get started on the
Ramsey plan
um my daughter actually introduced me to
it she's 12. but my concern is that I am
in the middle of changing homes a lot my
my life is turned upside down and so I'm
getting divorced how do you start a
budget when you don't even know what the
bills are going to be you know like I'm
going to be moving in three months I
just I'm not sure how to even get
started because right now I have joint
bank accounts and then it's going to
change to be mine so I'm just curious as
to any tips you have about that
horrible time of year to be going
through all that I'm sorry
the divorces
been filed as final as what
it should be final in the next two or
three months so and we've already worked
out most of the details with arbitration
okay then you should be able to close
your joint accounts today
already you should be able to if you if
you're in agreement on it
say probably in a month
yeah um so do not put any more money
into
a joint account your attorney should
have told you that
uh well I think my husband is keeping
the house that we're in and I'm moving
out and I think it was just because
that's what we've always been doing and
I guess no but you're not married
anymore soon
and
um what we've run into in 30 years of
doing what I do is that sometimes people
get right to this point and it suddenly
is not amicable and suddenly he takes
all the money out of the account and now
you're really screwed so you need to be
able to manage December
and you don't have any money
I do I have a separate that's what I'm
saying okay that's what I said to do all
right sorry good but most of our money
is in the join account okay but we need
we need to we need to bring the the cash
portion of this agreement to an end as
soon as possible and disperse so that
you can begin to set up that part now
here's the thing you can do a budget
this month
for this month
it'll never be like this again but for
this month you can say for December what
are my expenses and where's my income
and where's my cash going to go and then
for January I gotta move or I got to get
a different place or I got a deposit
it's going to be a different budget
right
okay and then February will be a
different budget but it always is
different you never do the same budget
every month some of them are more
similar than yours are going to be for
the next few months you're going to be
vastly different every month for a while
until it stabilizes but you have to tell
your money this month what to do before
it leaves because you're in the middle
of
um a hugely volatile crisis situation
and it will give you great peace if you
take control of this one area of your
life
okay well we pay all of our bills though
from the joint account and it's like
automatic so I like out of my personal
account I'm not paying any okay so what
is your budget for this month okay given
that the this weird joint account
situation that's in limbo is going to
take care of our bills but you still
have some things you have to do in
December as a newly independent person
right
and you need to write out that budget
there's probably not a lot to it is what
you're saying okay and uh but you need a
game plan all right and it might be that
I'm setting us out a pile of money
because in January after Christmas I got
to move out and I can need deposits
right
right I'm gonna actually buy my house in
cash wow
yeah I have an inheritance so
um I'm I'm gonna do that and all right
are you renting in between are you
jumping right into the home purchase
jumping right in
um it's yeah it's crazy but
I don't want to learn money at a high
interest rate and I've got the money and
the inheritance and I'm buying a
reasonable house you know like 260 000
um how much is in your inheritance
um my portion will probably be about 300
plus you don't have the money yet
oh I do
you said you're you if you don't if you
have the money you should know how much
it is
probably be well because I'm going to
give
[Music]
so it's much larger so it's all your
portion
and you have that already
yes okay so it's not probably be it's up
to you and so how much is your
inheritance that is in your account
uh
uh okay cool and so yeah because that
matters I mean if you got 200 262 000
and you're going to spend 260. that's a
little less reasonable oh yeah yeah well
I you know the other thing is that I'm
not settling the estate it's all mine
it's nearly settled until after the
divorce that way there's absolutely no
way that he can get it is what my lawyer
told me to do so like we have all the
papers ready to go but so you don't have
the 450.
have it I could settle the estate today
if I wanted to
but I'm choosing to wait until after the
divorce so that there's it's cleaner but
it's all in accounts and it's there's no
one else I got you okay
well the question was about starting the
budget starting this process and
budgeting is a habit and so you're it's
going to take you know on average it
takes 90 days to get a hang of this
budget and now is the best time to start
when you're in the situation you need to
be paying attention to where every
single dollar is going and protect it
because this marriage has become a
financial transaction and you need to
now stay protected yeah and let's get
the things unraveled as quickly as
possible
um
you're not gonna do this
but my advice to you would be to not buy
a house right now
uh you're hell-bent on doing this but
Sandy just in talking to you you're
chasing your tail through the whole
conversation I mean one minute it's one
thing one minute another thing we'll
miss another thing you don't you know
you're you're discombobulated all over
the place and you don't need to be
buying a house when your head's in the
space it's in right now uh and it's
normal transaction for us as we tell
people if you go through in the middle
of a major crisis where you're grieving
something like this I don't care if it's
a relief it's still a divorce it's still
one of the 10 things that'll put you in
the hospital it's still high stress high
anxiety situation unbelievable levels of
emotion and cortisol coursing through
your body and it affects your ability to
make decisions and just the conversation
with you is discombobulated and so I'm
just telling you you're my little sister
I would love you and tell you not to buy
a house right now just go rent something
for six months and let the emotional
dust settle you will make different
decisions and by the way don't commit to
giving any of this inheritance away for
six months let the emotional dust settle
um
there's all kinds of psychology behind
you're about to make mistakes here
um and but you're going to do whatever
because I can tell we're not going to
stop you but
um the way you do a budget is you do it
for that month
with what you have to work with and then
you do it for the next month with what
you have to work with and so you don't
have to wait until everything stabilizes
to start doing a budget as a matter of
fact the only way it will stabilize is
to do a budget this month and then do a
budget next month and then do a budget
next month and then you're stabilizing
what you can yeah they're not static
it's you know December has Christmas and
so that affects your budget for that
month and January is going to have its
own expenses and so you've got to be
restarting this process a lot of the
line items will stay the same but it
will fluctuate especially if you have a
regular income slowing down
on large giving decisions to relatives
that were not in the will slowing down
on large purchase decisions like a home
uh in the middle of this much upheaval
and volatility in your life is not fear
it is not weakness it is wisdom
so what we are recommending here is
wisdom we're not calling you weak or
inept we're saying you just got T-boned
and you're kind of Dazed and you're
walking around the intersection with
with little birds flying around your
head in a cartoon and you need to get
where you can sit down the curb for a
minute let your head clear before you
start admitting fault in this accident
that's what the kind of crap we're
dealing with here it's trauma